tout a augmenté mais c'est pas possible
que ça ait augmenté autant que ça c'est
impossible marie-jeanne bourderon en a
plus qu'assez de voir les prix augmenter
elle doute que l'inflation soit la seule
explication à ce phénomène
l'institut de la recherche et
d'informations socio économiques offrent
d'autres pistes selon son nouveau
rapport les profits des entreprises
canadiennes n'ont jamais été aussi élevé
en plus de 20 ans leurs bénéfices
auraient augmenté de plus de 10 % font
cours des quatre derniers trimestres une
entreprise qui ont été confrontés à
l'inflation ses coûts de production vont
augmenter cela étant dit manifestement
il ya eu aussi certains secteurs les
prix augmentaient encore plus que ce que
justicier déflation et selon le
chercheur les commerces d'alimentation
en auraient tiré avantage leurs marges
de bénéfice a plus que doublé depuis un
an encaissant plus de 3 milliards 600
millions de dollars en bénéfices
supplémentaires pendant ce temps à
l'épicerie les consommateurs commencent
à perdre patience hier une mangue
c'était 5 dollars une mangue on exagère
du prix du lait le beurre c'est la même
chose on est en train de s'en faire
passer eux notamment me suis rendu que
je mange la savane parce que c'est plus
stable à viande
le rapport de lyrisme fait fausse route
dénoncent certains à l'intersaison j'ai
pas une bonne nouvelle pour les pme il
provient pas des pme sont également des
consommateurs qui voient les effets
notation comme tout le monde donc je
vous dirais question ce sont des petites
et moyennes entreprises l'inflation
nouvelle en plus des hausses de salaire
pour aider les consommateurs l'iris
recommande au gouvernement d'accroître
la surveillance des entreprises pour
limiter les augmentations exagérées des
prix et leur propose de réduire les
tarifs d'électricité de services de
garde ou de transports en commun des
solutions peu efficaces selon une
économiste la fois de s'imposer
c'est la politique monétaire c'est le
taux directeur mais c'est encourageant
l'inflation ralentit aux états unis une
tendance que le canada pourrait
également observée dans les prochaines
semaines ici charles du boullay radio
canada montréal